hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round seven of
the feed a candidates tournament it's
fabiana carwana versus uh timur rajab of
uh both of them incredibly strong
players and you can only imagine that
the game will will also reflect um
such a thing but before we check out the
actual game which is quite a thriller
you guys will enjoy it uh let's check
out a photo between the two of them this
is a photo taken before the game this
mysterious uh woman is making the first
movie if anyone knows who it is do share
in the comments so we can all uh learn a
bit more i believe e4 uh was the move
that was played by her and it is the
move that fabi kept on the board uh
very very uh you can see that he is very
intense very much into the game waiting
to start uh fabi seems to be enjoying
the the floral pattern and uh well
that's um pretty much what we can get
from this photo and also i would like to
share one other photo with you it is
from a group of fans who ambushed nepo
after the game uh there it is uh it was
sent to me by the gentleman on the far
right lucious hunt uh so thank you for
that always enjoy nice photos uh with
with the players uh so hopefully you
guys will enjoy it as well maybe it will
encourage more of you to ambush the
players you know before and after the
games as that is always um you know good
memories and i also uh very much enjoyed
the matt murdock vibe from the gentleman
on the far left so i hope you hope you
enjoyed this now let's uh get to the
game as there is quite a lot to cover
and also yeah i forgot to mention today
is vladimir kramnik's birthday so if you
guys uh you know happen to run into him
uh you know on your way to a borrower
library do uh not forget to congratulate
him or rather wish him a happy birthday
now getting back to the game uh caruana
opens with pawn to e4 uh we have c5 by
rachael going after the sicilian defense
knight to f3 and now an incredibly rare
line and that is pawn to a6 this is
known as the o'kelly variation of the
sicilian defense uh and it is actually
uh black's fifth most popular reply to
white's knight to f3 in case you were
wondering uh so here uh usually it is
met by by just uh you know standard d4
or maybe c3 preparing d4 but uh fabi
goes for c4 he grabs the d5 square and
he says uh i i cannot lose this you know
but i i i can win it i can never lose
this position so okay knight to c6 we
have pawn to d4 striking in the center
captures captures and e5 now challenging
the knight you know while you could play
knight to c2 and it is the more popular
move fabi knows better and he goes
knight to f5 and already you have a
position where uh you know something
weird is happening you don't see this
every day just the white having a knight
on f5 on move six so d5 striking in the
center now also opening up an attack
against this knight c captures on the e5
and the bishop captures an f5 this is
all standard theory of course both of
them know this e captures on f5 and now
comes knight to d4 and bishop to d3
uh queen captures on the five knights
the c3 attacking the queen and queen
back to d7 usually bishop to b4 is
played here just spinning the knight but
here uh java goes queen back to d7 and
it is not as a move tender we have a
completely new game and it is quite a
position to
have in a candidate's tournament uh here
fabi castles we have uh knight to f6
continuing development and the bishop to
g5 putting pressure on this knight so
bishop to e7 and rook to e1 going after
the e5 pawn and interestingly here at a
job of just castle's queen side uh you
might think okay but wouldn't it be
better to just defend the pawn uh there
really aren't all that many moves that
defend the pawn that are that are good
for example if knight to c6 you defend
the pawn we're just going to capture and
after bishop captures bishop e4 uh we
put pressure on black's position we
offer a queen trade if you trade uh then
you haven't really accomplished anything
you're not going to be able to castle
queenside if you castle queenside then
the trader rook can come to d7 so again
it's not much and if you cancel queen
side which of course you can do then you
allow knight to d5 and it's just uh that
white is putting a lot of pressure on
black's position already so rajabov says
it's better to give up a pawn here and
to play actively so here queen side
castles and fabi says all right i'm
gonna grab the pawn uh show me what what
you got so knight to c6 attacking the
rook uh and bishop captures an f6 now
now if you capture the rook we capture
back with the bishop we have two pieces
for the rook so of course we're not
going to do that bishop captures and
rook to d5 now attacking the queen queen
to e7 and bishop to c4 so just nicely
keeping the tension we have kinked a b8
vita job off and now queen to d3
preparing to triple up on the d file uh
or maybe you know rook to c1 depending
on what our job of plays but he goes for
queen to b4
uh bishop back to b3 as the b2 pawn was
hanging and now knight the d4 putting
more pressure on the bishop and now even
though you want to play rook 8 to d1
maybe it just wouldn't make all that
much sense so we can just grab the
bishop here and you don't have any
pressure on the d file the bishop and
the rook control the the d8 square so
here you would basically just give up a
pawn which is not what you want to do so
queen to c4 fabio offers a queen trait
he is up a pawn so he is done with all
the traits uh queen captures bishop
captures and rook to c8 now putting
pressure on the bishop bishop back to d3
and now knight back to c6 and here just
bishop to e4 so fabi's up a pawn it's a
double death pawn but uh you know if
anyone is is playing for a win here it
is definitely fabi uh so here rook h to
e8 uh putting pressure on the bishop now
pawn to f3 and so far this bishop not
doing all that great work it it's for
the moment it's basically a pawn
but rajab has the thread carefully here
and the way you thread carefully is by
playing knight to e5 that's how you do
it and after white doubles up on the d
file you play rook to c7 and you are
very happy with your position you just
continue playing however rajab of played
rook to e7 here and it is a move that
allows fabi a bit too much as you'll see
uh rook 8 to d1 and now how do you
continue playing this position the
problem is the knight e5 idea that i
mean that's just the move that we want
to play it's a very active square for
the knight allows this very annoying
rook to d8 and now you really don't have
all that much here how how do you play
this uh if you play for example rook 8
you want to trade rocks okay we trade
rook captures king captures now bishop
to d5 you put pressure on the f7 pawn
now the knight cannot move now f4 will
dislodge the knight you're going to win
this pawn and if you play rook to e7
then knight comes to e4 and okay black
is you know hanging in there but it's
just a very very unpleasant uh you can
play an id6 check then we can capture on
on b7 uh it's just uh incredibly
unpleasant so rajab of plays h6 uh as
okay knight to e5 is no longer possible
now king f2 fabi now gets a brilliant
idea uh that he wants to start marching
his king up the board for the moment
it's not um it's not all that possible
but it will be a
very valuable tool in the future so rook
seat the c7 grabbing hold of the seventh
rank now rook five back to d2 as now
knight to d5 is a terrible threat so
rajab of trades the bishop for knight uh
he does not want to allow this knight to
d5 so bishop captures pawn captures
messing up fabi's pawn structure and
knight to e5 now
uh rook to c1 fabi defends the pawn here
and pawn to f6 but now uh fabi says now
i can do what i have planned king the g3
now the idea is king the h4 king the h5
kick away the knight from e5 to get grab
hold of the g6 square put the king on g6
and then somehow uh grab control of the
seventh rank win the pawn we win all of
these pawns and then win the end game so
if bobby can do that he can win the game
but that's a lot of moves so king to a7
arjaba also uh
has to figure out how to improve uh his
position and probably b5 he's going to
start pushing a5 before maybe try and
try and win the c pawn there are ideas
here so rook to d4 grabbing hold of the
c4 square and the fourth rank and rook
the c5 now we have king to h4 and rook e
to c7 successfully doubling up on the c
file but fabi just continues with his
plan king to h5 now uh
f4 is coming and then king to g6 and you
don't really gain all that much by uh
grabbing the pawn if you grab the pawn
we happily trade we push f4 you have to
move the knight we play rook to d7 grab
hold of this um seventh rank
you can't move the rook anywhere because
bishop captures on c6 and we're just
going to start pushing our pawns and win
the game so uh rajabo has to figure out
how to go about this he plays b5 now
comes f4 winning the g6 square so knight
to d7 and now not rushing with the king
but first rook c to d1 and this rook c
to d1 is not the absolute most precise
idea that you would expect from fabi
here knight to d7 actually allows this
incredibly strong bishop to d5 just
transferring the bishop over to e6 where
the bishop will be just a monster for
example knight b6 attacks the bishop
bishop p6 you've
improved your position so much that
there is really nothing for for black to
hope for here uh but okay it's a small
improvement that fabi maybe did not
consider necessary he played rook c to
d1 right away now he's just threatening
to win material knight to b6 and now
rook won back to d3 now of course you
don't have uh
the luxury of remaneuvering your bishop
so rook one to d3 sorry rook one to d3
uh and knight the a4 now going after the
c3 pawn this way and then the a2 pawn uh
and here fabi goes for king the g6
uh again maybe interesting uh line that
you guys as i enjoy you guys i know you
guys really enjoy uh uh cool lines uh
it's rook to d8 going for this rook the
a8 check forcing the king to be six rook
the d6 check forcing the king to a8 does
this uh bring do anything for white well
uh if knight captures on c3 rook to a8
with checking the b6 rook the d6 check
king to a5 and now rook captures uh on
a6 with check king to b4 now we're gonna
play bishop to d3 and okay of course um
this uh
knight now cannot capture on a2 we're
gonna play knight to d5 and now g3
defending on f4 and this is a
spectacular position for white where
black can only wait and see what what
fabi will do
but fabi goes for king to g6 right away
again he doesn't deem this uh maneuver
necessary uh we have knight captures on
c3 bishop back to f3 and now knight
captures on a2 so now the king was
needed here as the df5 pawn is also
under attack uh as the bishop moved away
from the defense so rook to d7 finally
winning the seventh rank and now knight
back to c3 we have king captures on g7
and now pawn to b4 with this pawn to be
for push rajabov reaches time control
this is mu 40 but his position is a
difficult one to hold now fabi grabs the
f6 pawn pawn to b3 and now rook to d2
and this is an incredibly important move
uh because uh if you just start uh you
know move the king you want to push your
pawns and you allow b2 that then you're
not going to win this game so this is
one move that you have to throw in in
between uh to stop uh black's
advancement so here we have pawn to a5
another very interesting idea is knight
to a4 just guarding the b2 square
preparing pawn to b2 but it doesn't
matter king g6 you play pawn to b2 we
play bishop e4 we guard the b1 square
and now even if knight to c3 uh sort of
preparing to push b1 you don't really
care rook characters on c7 rook captures
bishop to d3 and uh now there is uh well
just no good way no good way to do it
you're happy to give up the bishop for
the pawn because your passport will of
course win the game the black will have
to give up the rook for it and if
something like rook d7 uh you know going
for the bishop to promote your pawn we
just play rook captures on b2 we give up
the bishop anyway just throw captures
for example pawn to f6 rook to d6 we're
going to play g4 and the position is of
course winning for white knight to e4
we're going to play g5 captures captures
and next push the h pawn to victory so
knight to a4 not all that impressive for
a juggle he has to try something else he
starts pushing the a pawn
and now king e6 the king g6 or e6 it's a
matter of preference fabi prefers to
move the king to e6 rook captures on d7
rook captures with check and king to a6
now and now
uh fabi's at a turning point where he
has to decide whether to push f6 right
away or does he uh want to go for the
brilliant rook to d8 idea which we are
going to show as f6 is very very tricky
five we played f6 in the game but this
is so cool that we are going to show it
going after rook to a8 check to put the
rook on the uh on the a file and now if
rook to b5 of course you also have to
guard the b file as the b pawn wants to
advance now we're going to play rook to
a8 to check king to b6 and now pawn to
f6 pawn to b2 now pawn to f7 and once
black brings the queen into the game and
white brings the queen into the game
after queen to g6 check we want to block
with queen to f6 that's the point and
after the queen trade captures captures
and black starts pushing you say not a
problem king to g6 now we start pushing
our own pawn and your pawn can not
advance any further as it's uh
guarded by by the rook and if you try
rook to a5 it's not a problem you can
even trade captures captures and push f5
it's still winning for you because after
a3 and f6 you're gonna push pawn to a to
f7 you bring a queen into the game we
also bring a queen into the game but we
are still up upon and uh this will be
winning for white so it's it's a lot of
moves and a lot of pieces on the board
but uh of course both fabian and rajab
will know this and um
uh you know if it if if this was the
only winning idea fabi would play it but
he it's a very long line to calculate
and he doesn't think it's necessary so
he just goes for f6 right away we have
pawn to b2 now comes pawn to f7 and the
b1 queen so it's not
all that all that much different
because both players get a queen into
the game if you uh fabi did check for a
brief second whether he wants to go rook
to d6 check but this would uh you know
blunder the game for him this would
allow rajabov to draw so he goes for the
absolute strongest f8 queen and now uh
okay you could start checking the white
king with a2 with queen to b3 the
problem is after king to f6 there are no
more checks uh so you have to as the
bishop covers the c6 square so queen to
g6 is the only way to play this and now
favi blocks queen to f6 uh again we
could check out the trade captures
captures in the pawn push but after rook
d8 and going after the check it's not
possible rook c7 rook 8 check rook to a7
rook c7 rook c8 going after the knight
knight to b1 now we just played bishop
d5 we control the a2 square and that's
it now we just move the king start
pushing our pawn basically it's a lot of
moves but in all of these lines white is
able to stop black's progression or
rather the pawn pushing and you know
just uh stabilize and start pushing his
own pawns so queen to e8 with check
rajabo has to hope for something else
and now we have a king to d6
you could also play rook to e7 but this
would uh allow rajab to draw it's a it's
a very funny line so i will show it
because i know how much you guys enjoy
funny lines uh problem is after rook the
c6 check we give up the rook and after
bishop captures and queen captures look
at this this is spectacular king the e5
queen captures an f6 with czech king
captures knight to d5 with a beautiful
fork after that trade king of seven
knight captures king captures and now
pawn to a4 will ensure a draw f5.83 pawn
to f6 you guys okay already uh can
figure out the race it is black to move
with the queen and of course with the
open board you will very easily just
perpetually check the blood the white
king so after queen queen eight czech
king to d6 fabi finds the absolute
strongest idea rook to c4 and now rook
to c7 offering the trade and also if the
rook moves just denied the singing here
so king to b5 defending the rook and now
just queen e5 queen e5 check forcing a
queen trade and going into a winning end
game fabi did spend his time calculating
this a little bit but
uh it is definitely the way to go so you
have to trade otherwise your queen hangs
queen captures on e5 f captures on e5
and now rook captures on c7 there isn't
anything better really king captures and
now king to c5 now the problem is if you
start pushing right away the
white pawn queens with check that's the
problem so king
instead of pushing the pawn right away
king to c5 sidestepping a little bit now
pawn to a6 pawn to e6 knight to b5 check
came to d7 now pawn to a4 we have e7 and
he was in this position animal 56 that
temu rajabo resigned to the game and a
much needed victory for fabiano corona
in the end of the first half of the
candidates tournament in round seven of
the candidates uh as he is only half a
point behind yani pomshi as a if you've
seen the previous video yanipong she uh
got a brilliant brilliant victory if you
haven't seen it do check it out you will
you will really love it because rapport
uh pushed for more than anyone could
push for but in the end it was it was
nowhere near you know
what uh was possible still a very very
enjoyable game but yeah here you resign
because after knight to d6 topping
promotion uh just bishop d1 we go after
the pawn and after you push the pawn
bishop b3 and black is in absolute swank
there's nothing you can do here if you
pull the pawn you lose the pawn if you
move the king we pick up the knight and
then promote if you move the knight we
just promote so you can you know push a
few more moves but you know there's
no way to play this so of course after
e7 rejoice resigned and another
brilliant victory for fabiano caruana
who is like i said only half a point
behind janiponishi and uh it's gonna be
a a really really tough clash uh once uh
nippo and fabiano uh uh meet in the
second half of the candidates tournament
but you know we still have to check out
some other games we probably will cover
more games from this round uh so stay
tuned for that but yeah really really
impressive run from both fabiano and uh
nipponishi uh both uh both of them
former world champions championship
challengers uh it's definitely
definitely more than we could have hoped
for from this candidates tournament uh
so yeah sorry for a bit of a longer
video
there were really uh you know incredibly
enjoyable lines to show so hope you
enjoyed that uh i would like to thank
hans uh anderson uh uh amarillo
accounting spanish accountant in uk
brian tremper and jacob gonzalez and
stephen mcneil for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day